[Music]
gig work a great way to make some extra
Holiday Cash we shared those details
with you earlier in the month tonight
we're looking at how gig work can be a
great option for stay-at-home parents
even students who need a flexible
schedule during the school year and
holidays
it's not necessarily A this or that it's
a this and that when it comes to these
gig platforms the freelance and gig
economy has rapidly grown since the
pandemic gig work ideal for people who
need flexibility and want to be their
own boss Alex Atwood CEO of gravey works
as stay-at-home parents and students
make great candidates they have a lot of
the same needs if you're looking at all
of the obligations that comes with bids
having the holidays coming breaks off
from school planning for your own
holiday events doing your own Christmas
shopping time is somewhat constrained
during the holidays it's about
schedulizing when and where you want to
work monetizing time Atwood says things
have shifted a lot over the past few
years and as opposed to a year-long
commitment these days people committing
to hours in the day that makes things a
lot more flexible he's seen a huge
influx of people signed up on the gravey
work platform where people can find
hospitality and general labor shifts
right now hotels restaurants and event
venues are all searching for additional
staff when you apply to gravy work or
you apply to a lot of the gig economy
apps out there what happens is the whole
application process is all done while
you're onboarding through downloading
the app so you're answering all the
questions you're new you're adding it
references in real time and it's done in
such a way that makes it just super
simple
many Hospitality workers work full time
as there is almost no end to the jobs
available but if you
or need full-time work you can pick and
choose the gigs that work for you